just for a second you might say our next
guest knows a thing or two about legal
dramas yeah that's because he has
written check this out 47 consecutive
best sellers now get that one
is changing look at that wall right it
goes all the way over changing things up
a little bit with his first collection
of novellas called sparring partners the
three short stories about death money
and lawyers on the wrong side of the law
john grisham joins us first on cbs
mornings to tell us a little bit more
how you doing good morning good morning
guys happy to be here happy to have you
happy to have you now this is your first
collection of novellas um why try
something different at this point i've
tried everything so far except poetry
i've had short fiction nonfiction
uh you know bad fiction good fiction
i've tried everything um
short stories are kind of tough i'm too
long-winded for short stories
and too lazy for a big thick novel so
it's somewhere in between i really like
the length of it though and i'll
probably do it again so this was not an
accident
no i've been thinking about i've had
these stories for a long time
uh
there are three of them well the first
story goes back to the short story
collection 10 years ago
uh the middle story goes back to a short
story i wrote uh for a festival in italy
years ago so i had i've had the ideas
and as the uh birthdays keep going by i
realize these books are not getting
published so why not get them published
and so
here we are i know you know what john i
i was telling you i had a real nerdy
moment because i didn't read anything
about what this book was about before i
started right because i didn't want to i
didn't want any tip offs so i'm thinking
i read the first story then go to the
second then i go how is he going to tie
all these stories together then you
realize they're not supposed to be tied
together but they do have something in
common what is that lawyers what do you
expect
no but it's more than lawyers it was
something about the desire to escape
everybody has a desire to escape in all
the different stories yeah and a couple
of times you you take shots at lawyers i
wonder do you get a kick out of put
poking fun at lawyers that do not do the
right thing that was also very apparent
in this book yeah i've said i've said
for years most lawyers are honest
hard-working people don't make a lot of
money you don't want to read about those
folks that's not exciting you want to
read about the guy who steals the money
like mack in the first story yes uh
files for bankruptcy he flees in the
middle and leaves his family and goes to
the islands for a while that's what
happened in in the original short story
three years later he wants to come back
home he misses his daughters he he
thinks he's he could be in trouble he's
you know you can't live on the run yeah
he thought he could yeah it was a great
dream to escape and go to the beach it
doesn't work that way so he comes home
and then you have a death row story that
i thought was very different for you the
middle story strawberry moon is about
about the last three hours of a guy's
life he's a young man is about to be
executed um and all the appeals are gone
and
it's what you go through in those last
few hours and it's very it's very sad
but my favorite was the last story
because it's family drama brother
against brother brothers against father
there's a hero in the story a woman who
also works in the law office i like that
one that was going to be a novel i
thought i thought
it could be a it could be if i wasn't so
lazy but i wanted i want to i wanted to
uh you know
make it smaller
and uh shorter and more accessible and
uh it's a fun story did you enjoy this
process because it's very different from
all this i love to do what'd you love
about it
just to be able to tell three stories at
once i have a lot of stories i mean i
pick up stories all the time and and i
keep them for years the the good ones
become novels the bad ones go away but
there's always a list of stories
and i'm always
what is that process like when you say i
pick up stories all of the time
i picked up a story this morning in the
green room what was it johnny depp i
mean
i'm joking i'm just joking
we were all excited about it i was like
i would like to read john grisham's take
on that from malice i didn't know that
that's a whole new uh specialty of the
law uh-huh it's a fascinating story but
it is a fascinating
time joking you became a a writer to
escape the law now that you've got 47
consecutive bestsellers any part of you
want to escape this life or is it as
good as it looks it's good it's better
than it looks even better i'm still
having fun i still enjoy publishing the
books i enjoy writing every day
luckily there are a lot of ideas i've
never had a serious case of writer's
block and uh to get to come hang out
with you guys twice a year i'll be back
in october by the way with the next
thing here it's a big thick novel it's
not novellas
it's almost done so i'm having too much
i enjoy this you know what i like about
you two in addition i just think you're
a fantastic human being but i like your
stories never have your books never have
a preface that you get right into the
story i love that why do you do that
it's just storytelling yeah i think
old-fashioned
know you you start with the character
you start with the one plot you spin off
other plots and you and you take the
reader through this journey uh and you
keep the tension going which is
difficult the hardest part yeah uh but
you you lead up to an ending that you
hope is not predictable yeah uh i hate
it when people say oh i had that book
figured out halfway through right and i
want to say stop okay tell me the ending
because you're not going to get it right
uh that but it's a real challenge to
make the ending satisfying
uh but also unpredictable it's just it's
it's it's a it's a story it's
old-fashioned storytelling real quick
what is your advice to young writers
do it every day um
reps it's all about rest every day
practice every day do you still do it
every day
yeah five well five days a week when i'm
on my home and you're home okay john
grisham we appreciate you thank you so
much always fun guys swearing partners
thank you it's on sale now so make sure
you go get it it's an incredible book
like we expected